[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic book entertainment guess what
we're doing today guys that top 10
episodes of Batman the Animated Series
you you guys have been requesting it for
a long time and we're finally gonna go
into that before we go into the top two
episodes though I want to remind you
guys to like the Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome comics show
every Thursday we have the exclusive
video is going up on there a lot of
stuff recently so go back and check all
that out okay to talk about the top 10
episodes the Batman the Animated Series
we have two regular people that are on
the show but they're great people the
great folks great analyzers and analyze
these episodes I'll go with you first
what's your name Porter it's up broader
comma Brian Brian Porter that's his name
fantastic and you I Anna Anna wait and
yes contrary to popular belief I did
make it out of that chair from last I am
Alive I am fine it took the fire
department of life
Superman actually had to come off the
ride and come help me out but yeah fine
six flank trip is pretty fun little
terrifying - okay so we're gonna be
talking about spoilers for all these
episodes and there's a couple twists in
these episodes that you probably won't
want to know about if you haven't seen
it so as we're going through these stop
and watch the episodes and come back if
you haven't seen them because I think
you'll benefit more from that so where
do we go we're gonna be in like every
season - so we're not yeah we're just
the whole series we don't before so
we're gonna be all over the place all
over the place this is top ten episodes
the whole series here we go with number
10 Mad Love Harley Quinn tries to
impress her love while the origin of her
career as the Joker's sidekick is
revealed it's based on the one-shot
comic by Dini and Tim tell us a little
about Mad Love why do you like it so
much all right well the opening of the
episode is Gordon having to go in for a
dentist appointment and I love how he's
like I hate these appointments and then
we find out his dentist is actually the
Joker and I love that because Mark
Hamill will be able to say may the
philosophy yes I thought that it's like
one of the greatest things just being
like thank you thank you for that
yeah it was a good episode for sure and
this is the first time we see on screen
sort of the origin of Harley so Harleen
Quinzel we see her as the the
psychologist or therapist whenever an
Arkham Asylum and in her interactions
with the Joker the first kind and you
could see how she fell into it I'm happy
to start out just like a pure human you
know like she went in with like her own
intentions of being able to like make it
big with like the inside scoop
yeah exactly so she was she was no angel
to start with she wasn't and she chose
she chose this path for her life exactly
um there's some really great quotes in
this episode along like don't you want
to wrap up yeah hi like there's some
this is a really good quotable episode I
love it and the the death of a hundred
smiles with the piranhas yeah and you
get to see how Joker wants Batman dead
but he wants to be able to kill Batman
he doesn't want anyone else to have that
glory um so yeah that one of the
creepier things in this is Batman's
laughs which if you saw Killing Joke he
talked about Killing Joke a little bit
has laughs in that that's not really a
spoiler if you've read the comic
specifically just in the column maybe
Bruce Wayne but yeah it was a little
weird well yeah mad loves great it's
based off the book like you say which is
right here this is one of the picks of
the week go ahead and check this out
it's more detail than the episode it's
got some really good stuff in this we go
look at that alright moving on to number
[Music]
his silicon soul so hard AK his robot
replica of Bruce Wayne wanders around
believing itself to be the real Batman
this is a sequel to heart of steel parts
1/2 a hiss silicon soul was really cool
this is one of the most memorable
episodes I remember this one as a kid so
like in the heart of Steel episode
they're called replicants that hard act
mates hardac is this giant computer this
evil giant computer which is very you
know like Superman 30s 40s kind of thing
but it's really cool he like makes
replicants of people so it's kind of
like invasion of the Body Snatchers
except at the end of that episode you
see that there is a Bruce Wayne
replicant made and we don't know what
happens to him until this episode so
he's wandering around and he thinks he's
Batman he thinks he's Bruce Wayne until
he gets wounded in the stomach area and
has robot parts and he's very confused
eventually he know he finds out who he
is heart attacks or downloads himself
into that version of Bruce Wayne and
it's sort of a nature versus nurture
thing because this hard act made this
version of Batman this Bruce Wayne so
accurate to the real Bruce Wayne Batman
that he's fighting against the evil of
replacing humans with replicants it's
just such a cool back and forth and an
inner struggle that's Batman but not
Batman
I like the quote that in it - of when
he's trying to figure out what's going
on like what what's why am I my robot
I've like had my brain implanted in a
robot and they're like no you're just a
robot all you have is memories
information data nothing more mmm like
Jim what's the last time you tasted a
really good steak or like something like
that like you don't have any feelings
you just have facts cold hard facts and
I love that like moment for him and I
love being able to see really cool and
then at the end when you kind of
sacrifices himself the the brain he
thinks he does it's it's very like a
paradox for him it's like I have to do
this because these are my internal
commands
however my internal commands are saying
I can't take a life as Batman it's a
destroy that upload exactly and at the
end it's very cool that little quote and
says is it possible that he had a soul
Alfred a soul let's move on to number
eight old wounds Dick Grayson reveals to
his successor Tim Drake the secret of
the strain relationships with his mentor
Batman and Barbara Gordon okay this is
the season four episode this is an
episode that sort of ties back to the
original first three seasons
it shows how Dick Grayson has Robin left
Batman and that the whole butting of
heads between them it's really like kind
of emotional at some points and it the
whole episode is really strong it
character-wise and you could see how it
became Nightwing in a sense and
everything you see like a darker side to
Batman yeah yeah and that's kind of
where Robin starts to separate from him
I think any favorite moments from this
one do you remember like the whole
episode is just really emotional later
you know I don't really have any like
specific moments that stand out to me
right this episode I just remember like
being like when dicks telling him like
you're like whoa like his family's here
but then at the end you find out that he
works for Bruce Wayne now and Bruce
Wayne like always checks up on him so
that was a nice little callback to the
game episode also there is the big
reveal from Batman to Barbara Gordon
that you know he reveals who he is that
he's Batman and he reveals that he knew
who she was the whole time
yeah and that kind of is a betrayal to
dick too because they were dating at the
time and everything so it's very and
then we know what happens later because
that's in this continuity with Batman
and Batgirl is still gross to me but
whatever yeah moving on to number seven
[Music]
over the edge Batman and his allies
apparently have their secret identities
exposed and are now hunted by the police
so in this episode it's a really good
fat girl episode so obviously I love it
and this is the one where we get to see
like a Bruce versus Gordon which is
really cool because you can see best
friends like at each other's throats a
civil war if you will and Batgirl dies
in it but it's revealed at the end again
spoilers that it's just her dream air
crew right so it's not actually
happening but it's really cool to see
like how the secret of her being back
girl is just eating away at her and I
like I like that because she and her
father have such like a really good
relationship throughout the series and
they're so close and even though
sometimes he like babies are a little
bit she has a really interesting way of
handling that where she's like dad I get
that you have like the best intentions
for me but also it's because I'm back
this was specifically was really weird
to be watch after Killing Joke because
she had such a difficult time like being
able to like confront Gordon at the end
like after her like fever dream she
actually does go to her dad and try to
explain who she is and he's kind of like
you don't have to finish that sentence I
I know you know which I like I know but
we don't have to it doesn't have to go
said which is like really cool but if
she has that much trouble telling him
that she's Batgirl
imagine me what she would have would you
told her oh by the way I'm screwed your
best friend oh so like this one
specifically was very very weird after
Killing Joke I agree with you but it is
a really good alternate a con things you
don't know what's happening at the
beginning because they're being chased
by the lot of them storming the Batcave
yeah it looked really cool right and
friends fighting each other great
conflict it's interesting to see that
Gordon how much Gordon does know in that
month yeah I mean it like that expected
things that he kind of at least has a
really good idea yeah he was able to
actually be a detective and stuff
without even Batman knowing okay moving
on to number six Joker's wild when the
Joker learns that a casino owner is
using his likeness for the theme of his
business he escapes Arkham Asylum to
destroy it while unaware of the owners
real motives
I love Joker's wild because of the
beginning in the end and we get to see
them in Arkham and him trying to watch
TV and him and poison ivy and then at
the end like them being like hey no we
were watching that and there's a little
bit of Looney tune I know
whistling the theme song yeah I like I
like the like little bow wrap of the
package of this episode that they do at
the beginning in the end but this is
this is a good Joker episode
specifically because we get to see like
his motives for stuff and him like
trying to blow up the casino and trying
to destroy this casino cuz yeah well
we'll talk about it later with his face
in in a couple
episodes for now but he he has a brand
and so someone like tried to steal his
brand and his brand is very important to
him that right of his career so it's
really interesting to see hey I'm trying
to do this whole thing for the whole
episode and then at the end being like
wait he wanted this with me oh I don't
want to blow it up then that's training
I'm being used yeah exactly and Joker's
is not very you know keen on being used
sure okay user not to use exactly
alright moving on to number five legends
of the Dark Knight several children give
their widely varying opinions of who
they think Batman is this is an awesome
episode because of the like callbacks to
the Dark Knight and then the 60s Batman
and we get these awesome alternate uh
you know animation styles and with the
regular animation styles like it's just
visually it's very entertaining and then
just just the the content of it you know
they I feel like they cover like the
legends of the dark era The Dark Knight
Returns I feel like they really grasp
that yeah not only in the animation but
in the style of the storytelling and
also in the very very campy 60s version
right in the way the Joker looks and how
they defeat everybody in their dialogue
it's just it really captures that era of
Batman over actors to using different
voice actors for each little like story
is really interesting if the animation
that they used to yeah
yes it's really awesome I just love the
way that they did indicate versatility
of the show I would say I grew total of
being able to have such an iconic figure
and you can play around with him for an
episode and still it feel like it's
still the same show my favorite part of
the episode though is that dig at
Schumacher like the pink Bowl oh yeah
yeah you're tacky and I think right but
yeah they do take it a pretty hard dig
in them there
and I'll do commentary for this they
talked about how the the Dark Knight
Returns portion of this is like the
closest you're ever gonna see to the
screen but then years later yeah I came
out with the movie which is one of the
best DC animated movies absolutely part
one and two okay let's move on to number
four
[Music]
shadow of the bat parts 1 & 2
Commissioner James Gordon is arrested
for corruption forcing his daughter
Barbara Gordon to make a dramatic step
to help him first official appearance of
Batgirl in the series let's be real I
love this up so it's a great great
Batgirl episode and it's the first like
episode that we see her origin man which
is really cool
Gordon is arrested at the beginning of
part 1 and it's because he's allegedly
taking bribes right and Barbara is
saying you know trying to help him and
everything and she says to Batman like
you gotta help him if you're if you just
show up it'll it'll be like such a great
like symbol for the people that you
support him and that he's innocent and
he's like Mac and Sarah can't do it and
she's like oh okay
well you'll be there one way or another
and then we get to see her donning the
suit and you can tell right away based
on like the physicality of the character
that it's not Batman like before you
even see like that yeah obviously the
busty or the usual you can see right
away like that's something fishy about
that me right just the first like shot
of him and and then the little reveal
with the like pulling off of the cowl
you see her hair her hair and oh wait
it's bad girl and there's some to face
in this one
yeah and stuff like that and I like the
quote towards the end to this is in part
two yes we mashed you episode together
and deal with it but it's at the end of
Part two when she's saving the guy and
he's like oh I didn't I didn't know it
was you versus would it have made a
difference I love that bit where as if
he knew like oh it's Barbara I'm sorry
about that I just thought it was Batgirl
right and the the back-and-forth between
Robin and Batgirl and this too is like
little Clippy stuff I love that stuff
too I like it because it kind of reminds
me of the Batman eternal the like the
first issue of an eternal from a couple
years back with Scott Snyder you know
Gorgias arrested and but for different
reasons but you know bat girls
like holy my dad's arrested I gotta
fix this and she's all crazy and all it
and it's like I wonder if signer got any
Batgirl is around Commissioner Gordon -
as Batgirl and Commissioner why don't
you go with our guy dad wait I mean
that's laughing speaking of laughing
let's go to number three
[Music]
The Laughing fish The Joker starts
threatening the Patent Office staff when
they refused to patent his disfigured
smiling fish I love this episode
personally this is my favorite episode
of all the entire series I remember
seeing it as a kid in the early 90s like
I don't really remember too many from
when I first first saw it I remember
seeing it as a kid and being creeped out
by you know that cat scratching you
Batman and the cow turns out to be the
Patton officer guy laughs and the way
you look oh and his neck was like like
really like the animation styled crazy
and then that cat laughing it's like a
deep like howling laughs almost with the
fish in the mouth oh yeah really scary
and just I just remember the fish I
always and I've thought about it just
randomly when I think about the Joker
and you know Batman the Animated Series
my mind always goes to the Laughing fish
and it's been that way for 20 years
yeah God but I love that episode so much
and it's so funny and just did the Joker
trying to patent his face and then
selling it that commercial that he does
and is so funny it's just yeah I
remember this with him at the Gordon
fish
exactly this joker episode 2 and the
showdown they have at the end at the
rooftop very very good stuff yeah I love
it and he pulls the floaty out and great
stuff okay like yeah there's a couple of
quotes I like from this episode the
Harley is a mermaid when you're just six
and the happy meal it's a happy meal
okay and then like earlier in the
episode when someone says Great Scott he
goes actually I'm Irish right well
there's some really good quick be like
dialogue and there's it's funny it's
scary it's very very good it's very
Joker yes definitely
moving on to number two the where the
Gray Ghost a series of bombings
reminiscent of a long-lost TV series
occur and the washed-up star of it may
be connected Adam West as Simon Trent or
the Gray Ghost obviously I love this
episode because Adam West isn't it what
a great I love when they use different
voice actors throughout the series that
kind of give little hints like like will
not towards other Batman and stuff and
Adam West being in this episode as a
Batman ask character yeah it's so good I
love that image of him trying to watch
the old series Bruce Wayne trying to
watch the the series with Alfred playing
it on the projector and it does this
like shot where it spins around him yeah
image of just him as like young Bruce
Wayne with Thomas Wayne great that whole
animation yeah that's I think that might
be one of my favorite parts of this
episode this is personally like my
favorite episode series it's just so
well done
and there's a little thing at the end
with the villain guy who's the toy shop
owner 12 like that's Chris job yeah and
I love that he's talking about like toys
and stuff though because of all the
burgers Tim like merchandise there is
you know the it's really cool to see him
like giving a monologue about toys and
the power of merchandise and stuff like
that
talking about toys can be used for good
or for evil they can carry bumps or they
can inspire yeah yeah I love this
episode too it's yeah it's just amazing
and I love the great ghost costume yeah
yeah the theme is really good I know
[Music]
cuts back and forth when you get to see
the parallels of the Gray Ghost in the
Batman yeah so well done and I love how
like you know he was inspired by you
know the spirit and the shadow and
there's little drawbacks or like little
callbacks to that with like there's this
one where he's kind of silhouetted like
in the shadows or whatever the Gray
Ghost and like the poster or whatever
yeah and you know just just like the
shadow and was like hot that's really
good season one to you guys like it's
starting off so early oh yeah there's a
poster somewhere in the film are
somewhere in the episode talking about
Clayface what's his first name
yeah Hagen they said no Hagen the actor
or the man of many faces or something
like that's a nice little sword
shattering Thanks all right
well we gotta go on to number one here
and we won number one for a chance to
dream after being knocked out in a
mysterious warehouse Batman wakes up in
a world where his parents are alive he's
engaged to Selina Kyle and someone else
is Batman yes this is our collective
number one my personal number one as
well I love perchance to dream I think
is a great example of why the Mad Hatter
is a fantastic villain that needs a
live-action interpretation absolutely I
understand that you know the giant depth
thing with the house I'm wondering what
has kind of made him sort of
unattractive now you don't play him you
don't have him play him of course
Ward I have I would have to think about
would you have I think he's I think he's
a frickin great villain and it's because
of this kind of stuff like the mind
control sort of going in and changing
everything it just it's oh it's there's
so many cool Easter eggs in this in this
episode when things are kind of starting
to go a little weird that's when you
here like very subtly the the Mad Hatter
theme is in there and then it builds up
and builds up and builds up until that
that clock tower or whatever that church
steeple thing at the at that graveyard
when Batman fights batman bruce wayne
fights batman just again to fight
himself
and verse itself and then seeing his
parents and then having his pants row
Kevin Conroy voice his dad was awesome I
think that worked really well I like oh
we've got an appointment to golf
yeah but there's that moment where he
believes that it's real he completely
buys into it for a few minutes and it's
like oh this is Batman this is Bruce if
you you know he would have just been a
good-hearted regular guy and if his
parents didn't die in that horrible way
and they play the Batman theme you know
dant and today but it's all it's very
like majestic and happy and it's so
weird but I love it yeah it's I love
this episode so much Batman has a little
hope in his life it's Harper he like has
a little bit where he's like but I could
be happy they're just like moments of
that throughout Batman's career when
you're like you could never be happy and
the little line that Mad Hatter has with
the I would have given you any life just
to stay out yeah yeah and then at the
end the best quote from this absolutely
of course is at the end like what if
you're wrong he's about to jump off the
tower and kill himself he says then I'll
see you in your nightmare
so good it was originally supposed to be
that I'll see you in Hell right but they
couldn't get it past the censors even a
almost like Batman which is so cool that
like in his dreams he has nightmares
about that
yeah I really like I kind of like that
sign there's it fits in with the the
dream episode the whole thing better I
kind of like that but it's just still
kind of cool duh I know I wish we could
like if there was like a deleted scene
where they actually had that in there
just just having really you can kind the
next time I just happen to see
I actually met him years ago and I tried
to get him to record my voicemail and he
said no that's where I got the thing I
know okay well those are our top 10
episodes those are collective we all
three like looked over these and picked
collectively what we thought was the top
10 our actual top 10 individual lists
are a little bit different so maybe
we'll tell you those at a later date
a couple honorable mentions will talk
about here Pete were just really quickly
I'll just mention them POV was one of
yours Harley an IV loved Harley and
Iovine anything together because they
ship forever Satana baby doll mine
paging the crime doctor love it Robins
reckoning the origin Robin - I am the
night Batman kind of gives up the
environment for a bit that's fantastic
it's never too late is a great story
it's barely about Batman Batman's like
guardian angel and it's just freaking
great and almost got him which is number
one episode opening of that is so
amazing with just the hands like with
such a strong character design you can
literally recognize everyone's hands
right like jelly
during the poker game and then at the
end the reveal of Batman with the
swinging of the light with Killer Croc
that that episode to me is just so
visually you can just just visualize
everything in that episode it's amazing
you're right okay go and go on to the
picks of the week I got a couple for you
here so we talked about Mad Love already
well you know read this if you liked the
episode it's a great expansion on that
it came out before the episode also I
brought Batman black and white volume 1
and 2 volume 1 has a story from Bruce
Timm in it that's really cool it's a
two-faced story really fun and volume 2
has a Paul Dini story in it which is
talked at length about Paul Dini on the
show it's a great ready for Batman
series so if you like him you like
historian here and it's a bunch of
different stories like little stories
and Batman black and white and go check
out that line it's really cool
also I have a book that I forgot to
bring but it's really cool to call
Batman animated it's this big book that
has they came out I think at the end of
the 90s that talks about the entire
series it gives little tidbits about
things like original animation cells are
in there and stuff and it's really fun
go check that out it's a picture of it
that's up right now if you're checking
you out it's a great book and if you're
fan of the show
get that book it's really old but you
could find it somewhere online on
or something it is a great book for a
big Batman the Animated Series fans so
go ahead and check that out okay
what do you guys want to see us do a top
10 episode of next
just leave some comments let us know
there's a lot of animated shows that I
would love to talk about at length more
and pick 10 episodes out with these guys
so go on and ask us about that
ok so social media if everybody where
can we find you facebook.com slash
awesome porter that's great that's a
facebook website and it has awesome poor
at the end you Facebook ad Ayanna Wade
or Twitter and then I also just got a
snapchat fan snapchat a lot of you know
it's awesome Iona so I put a blanket
term these guys yeah cuz were awesome
and we had a lot of behind the scenes at
Six Flags and us on the rides and stuff
on that so yeah come check out my story
it is just these guys you can follow me
on twitter at awesome underscore walter
asking about this about the top 5 show i
do and you guys want to suggest stuff
for that go ahead and talk to me on
there I love talking you guys about and
you always get get at us on our awesome
comics show Facebook page facebook.com
slash awesome kind of show we're always
on there so if you want to talk to us
we'll be on there okay so until next
week what's your name one more time
Brian Porter what's your name Oh Ayanna
wait and I'm all turbine asiak and until
next week we'll see you on the next page
[Music]
you